and
we are looking in live now at the u.s
department of treasury
where treasury secretary tim geithner
will speak at a forum recognizing the
contributions of women
in the financial sector his remarks to
be followed by two panels focusing on
the economic recovery and challenges
women face in the financial community
participants include the heads of the
fdic
small business administration and
securities and exchange commission also
later a luncheon address
by senior white house advisor valerie
jarrett
looking in live here and there is
secretary geithner coming into the room
also today president obama is expected
to
sign the completed health care bill into
law
and we'll bring you updates on that as
the schedule is firmed up
watching live coverage here on c-span
three
good morning ladies and gentlemen good
morning good morning ladies and
gentlemen please take your seats
the program is about to begin please
take your seats
also a friendly reminder please turn off
all cell phones blackberries and pagers
thank you
good morning my name is rosie rios
treasurer of the united states
and welcome to the women in finance
symposium hosted by the department of
treasury
and the white house council on women and
girls
thank you all for joining us today for
what will truly be a historic event
not just for treasury and the
administration but to all current
and future generations of americans and
beyond who will be inspired
by today's activities i would now like
to introduce
secretary tim geithner
good morning welcome to treasury thanks
for coming
i want to start by thanking rosie rios
let me say it again
treasurer of the united states cool
title
much better title much better job than
being secretary of the treasury
i'll tell you that rosie's leading
helping lead a national effort to
improve
financial education and i want to thank
her for taking the initiative
to bring this remarkable group of women
together to help advance the cause of
women
in finance women in business women
economics women and finance
i picked up this new york magazine
article
last week the article that asked the
question what if
women ran wall street and i thought now
that's an excellent question
but it's kind of a low bar how
you might ask could women not have done
better
today in america three of the past four
secretaries of state of and women
nancy pelosi is speaker of the house a
strong and powerful speaker of the house
but only seven percent of fortune 500
ceos are women
only two to three percent of finance
company ceo's women says ruth barat this
morning
only 17 percent of seats in congress are
held by women
and if you walk the halls of treasury
and you look at the gallery of portraits
of my predecessors
or if you look at the past chairman of
the federal reserve board or past
presidents of the new york fed you'll
see a striking
similarity among all of us
the federal government still does not
provide paid parental leave
women who graduate from college today
get paid 20 percent less
than men despite higher average gpas
this is not a record to be proud of
now the president and the congress are
working to make things better first bill
i didn't know this but the first bill
the president signed into law was the
lilly
better fair pay restoration act and the
house is working to pass i think the
house is passed
congress is working to pass a federal
employees paid parental leave act
but there are deep disparities in
opportunities for women in business and
finance
and the business community should have a
strong interest in removing those
disparities
catalyst which is a leading organization
working to expand opportunities for
women in business
found that women with more women
companies with more women on their
boards
outperform those with less women by 66
percent
now our hope is this symposium today
will help re-energize an important
national conversation
about how to improve opportunities for
women and finance
this morning you're going to hear from
women who now preside over key parts of
the american financial system
who helped shape the government's
response to this financial crisis
and who are working to reform this
broken system
elizabeth warren is one of the most
powerful most compelling most talented
advocates for reform in the country
mary shapiro leads the renovation of the
securities exchange
commission christy romer a
scholar one of the leading scholars in
the country of the great depression
helped this president design the package
of policies that pulled us back from the
financial
abyss and have and have created the
prospect of a growing economy again and
sheila bear is now presiding over
the most complicated the most difficult
um
the most consequential restructuring of
the american financial system
uh since the great depression now this
discussion today is about
two basic tests of values and governing
the first is about the proposition and
this is something i know the president
feels very strongly about
that you get the proposition you get
better judgments you get better
decisions and you get better results
when you're exposed to a diversity of
opinion of background
and experience the second is about
opportunity
and about fairness the critical test
of justice in any society is whether
people face equality in the
opportunities presented to them
the chance to advance and to excel on
the basis of merit
and effort and drive and dedication
we can all do better on those tests now
we've seen a financial crisis
that's caused a huge loss of faith and
trust and confidence
in our financial system and
we hope that's gonna provide an
opportunity for women to come into this
world
and help rebuild help restore that trust
and confidence
and as women think about what they're
gonna do with their lives as they come
out of school now
think also about coming to work for your
country think about public service
you're still going to have clients if
you work in government
and the demands that come with clients
but your clients the american people and
it is a
great and noble and consequential and
rewarding thing to do
so i hope we see more of you in the
halls of government
thank you very much
thank you secretary geithner it has
truly been an honor to serve you
and this administration and i would like
to especially acknowledge
your leadership and your vision but
mostly your courage
for supporting me since my first day
that i arrived here in treasury and
especially for your support
making my dream of the women in finance
symposium a reality
we are here to celebrate the 30th
anniversary of the national women's
history project
to recognize the accomplishments of
women in finance
today and in the past and to encourage
women
and girls across the country to become
leaders
in the field today's symposium is an
opportunity for dialogue
across the public and private sectors
with women well established
in their careers leaders in the private
sector who will be on the second panel
and we'll also we would like to thank
for coming
women who are well established in their
careers and others with their full
careers before them
like the students at stockton college
pepperdine
and howard universities along with many
others engaging in today's symposium
via live webcasts
earlier this month president obama
issued a proclamation
of women's history month which said the
following
as we honor the women who have shaped
our nation we must remember that we are
tasked with writing the next chapter
of women's history only if we teach our
daughters
that no obstacle is too great for them
that no ceiling
can block their ascent but we inspire
them to reach for their highest
aspirations
and achieve true equality these words
resonate for me especially today
never have i been more hopeful for my
nine-year-old daughter brooke
than i am now looking out in the
audience of accomplished women
and seeing how far we have come thank
you
but as we look towards the future we
should begin by examining our past
the theme for this year's national
women's history project is riding women
back into history so it is fitting to
open the day with some of the remarkable
women in treasury's past
and their significant accomplishments if
you look at the windows
lining this room you will see images of
women each telling her story
of her contributions to this great
institution
the first women were hired by the
treasury department well over 200 years
ago
in 1795 sarah waldrake and rachel
summers were hired as adjusters for the
mint
and earned 50 cents a day they weighed
gold
coins and filed them down to the correct
way
helen bennett was the first professional
woman hired to work in the treasury
building in 1861.
she worked in subterfuge copying and
recording in the name of her ill husband
no one officially acknowledged her
existence as she earned sixteen hundred
dollars a year
in her husband's name three years later
when women were allowed into her clerk's
role
their salaries were capped at six
hundred dollars
now i can say with a bit of pride that
it was the office of the treasurer which
helped truly bring women
into treasury in 1862
during the civil war francis spinner
treasured the united states
approached then secretary of the
treasury salmon p chase
and said to him i want to employ women
and as was the case for most wartime
experiences when men were scarce
women were hired in mass women quickly
flourished
just two years after spinner approached
chase mrs willard a leonard was hired by
the treasurer as the chief counterfeit
detector
and won nationwide reputation as the
female sherlock holmes
she gained fame as the most remarkable
woman in government and it's claimed
that in her 41 years on the job
she never made an error the female
sherlock holmes is one of many
exceptional women to grace treasury's
halls
to your left for example the first black
woman
who was hired in treasury was sophia
holmes mrs holmes a free native of
washington
worked as a custodian in the division of
issue at fifteen dollars a month
and became famous for finding and saving
the division two hundred thousand
dollars
that had just been mistakenly thrown
away as trash
when she died in 1900 at 79
secretary of the treasury lyman gage was
among the most
was among the notables at her funeral
another woman an unnamed mathematician
hired in the early part of the 20th
century
was so bright that congressional members
repeatedly asked her to interpret charts
charts and graphs for them and in 1949
georgia niece clark was appointed the
first woman treasurer by president
truman
and the position has been held by a
woman ever since
women have filled other leadership roles
throughout the years in general counsel
assistant secretary and deputy assistant
secretary rules
recent standouts even include one of our
panelists
sheila bear who served as assistant
secretary for financial institutions
from 2001 to 2002.
so as we honor this this 30th
anniversary of writing women back into
history
our goal with the symposium is with an
eye to the past
to begin writing women into the future
too often girls are told what subjects
they should study what interests they
should have
and what jobs they should do to all the
young
girls students and young professionals
who are watching us today
it's okay to be good at math and science
it's okay to study economics and it's
okay to enter a field
dominated by men we need you
follow your dreams and one day you will
be the leaders of this nation
leaders in finance leaders in economics
and leaders in government
and one day one of you may stand before
us as secretary of the treasury
the women you will see today on the
panels in the hallways
and on the walls of this room have
blazed a trail for you
but it's up to you to reach that
mountaintop and for all of us
to help you get there thank you
i would now like to introduce our
moderator for the first panel
maria bartiromo our first panel
titled women drivers of the economic
recovery pathways to success
will be moderated by ms bartiromo anchor
of
cnbc's closing bell and host of the wall
street
journal report an award-winning
journalist and author
in 1995 maria became the first
journalist to report live
from the floor of the new york stock
exchange on a daily basis where she
covered breaking news for the network's
unscripted
and fast-paced business morning program
squawk box
she's been an eager supporter of the
symposium and we're very happy that she
was able to join us
maria
thank you very much great to see you all
i am thrilled to be here with you and
honored to share the stage
with the women who are on their way up
but first we're going to take the podium
down
sheila bearish chairman of the fdic mary
shapiro chairman of the sec
christian romer head of the president's
economic advisory council
and elizabeth warren overseeing the
congressional
commission on the tarp program ladies
great to have you here and thanks so
much for having me
here in washington to talk with you
again i'm honored to share the stage
with such accomplished women and the
senior women of the administration and
government today
um i thought we'd start by just giving
us a sense of your day-to-day we want to
have a couple of goals accomplished
today number one
we'd like to uh talk about your road to
where you are today
certainly we'd like to get a lot of
feedback from everyone in the audience
and on twitter and on email
get your questions answered and we'd
also like to talk about the environment
today
so elizabeth can you kick us off what is
your day today like tell us about your
job
uh and i'm located still in the academic
world
and uh so my days consist of things like
teaching
and uh office hours and the like and in
addition to that
i uh do the congressional oversight
panel
uh we turn out a report every single
month it's like doing a term paper
every 30 days on some aspect
of tarp and how the money's been spent
and and whether or not we're
accomplishing the goals we should be
accomplishing
and the third thing i do is that i
continue to work on my academic research
and to talk about it since i've been
talking about the economics of middle
class families for
a very long time now to advocate for
change in the financial system that
would be
helpful to those families sort of take
them out of the
line of gunfire that they've been in do
you pinch yourself having uh achieved
what you have
do i do i mean how do how does it feel
do you pinch yourself that you're in
this position
you know i i find myself amazed
all the time but listen i have to tell
you i've been amazed for 25 years
i'm still amazed uh i i wake up every
morning and this is the truth
you know in that instant when your brain
is awake but your eyes haven't opened
yet
and i think about what i'm going to get
to do today
and and my eyes fling open and i'm ready
to go
that's great because i'm always amazed
by what i'm going to get to do christina
how about you tell us about your day to
day
so i'm listening to elizabeth's
description that used to be my day
yes and that all changed pretty
medically
a year ago january so my day-to-day
is uh incredibly varied it often
uh involves meeting with the secretary
of the treasury and the other
people on the economics team often with
the president it has certainly been
an incredible year of
economic issues i think never has there
been
a time when economics was as front and
center
everything from the recovery but to
financial
rescue and now regulatory reform to
health care i think that's been probably
you know the part of my life i least
expected was
i think somebody said no matter what
kind of economist you were when you
started
when you come to washington you become a
healthcare economist because that is
the number one issue affecting the
budget affecting people's lives
affecting the economy
and that's certainly been true for me
and it's i think a role the ca is after
so every day you get up and you you have
meetings on the calendar with the
uh secretary of the treasury with the
president of the united states
how many times a week do you meet with
those two individuals well i see tim
almost every morning so we both have
their senior staff
and then you know i think in a typical
day there's at least
one or two meetings on economic issues
with all of the economic principles and
certainly in the beginning it was every
single day with the president
actually my husband once i came home one
day and i said i can't believe it i
had to meet with the president for three
hours
and my husband said i'd listen to what
you just said
exactly but i had work to do but
it is i have the i have the the pinch me
moment
and mine is usually i'm walking into the
west wing at some points you just want
to go
i can't believe i'm here amazing dictate
when that happens walking into the west
wing and
that's terrific christina mary you
certainly have great endeavors
uh on your plate tell us about your day
today what what does it look like
probably three words meetings meetings
meetings but i think of them as breaking
down into what i view as my three jobs
at the sec
one has been to kind of reinvigorate and
redirect the agency back towards its
core mission
investor protection market integrity
bringing in new leadership
trying to change our culture a little
bit the second has been to be engaged in
regulatory reform and all the
legislative proposals that we've been
commenting on and working with congress
and the administration on over the past
year
and then the third is to really launch
the sec's um
investor-focused agenda of rule-making
and enforcement cases so
um while it's all meetings it's on lots
of different subjects which makes the
job fascinating
and in these really three major areas of
interest at the moment
what's most extraordinary about all of
you is that not only
do you have enormously important jobs
and
enormously important issues on your
agenda every day
but we are in this particularly uh
amazing moment in time and have been for
the last year and you've all been so
critical
to the economic recovery sheila bear
your job as well
amazing uh the number of banks that uh
have failed that you have
uh been showing true leadership uh in
this recovery tell us about your day to
day
well uh we are uh bank failures
obviously are first and
foremost on our minds these days and
always making sure that insured
depositors are absolutely protected as
they always are
and and have been for throughout our 76
year history
so we spend a lot of time making sure we
identify well in advanced banks that
will fail and planning appropriately and
making sure it's a smooth transition
uh for bank customers uh when it happens
uh we're currently evaluating uh the
structures we use to bid out failed
banks so to see if we can get some
better pricing as the markets recover
we want to get a little more innovative
uh in what we're doing including perhaps
launching some securitizations
uh we also have an insurance component
the fjc actually is a very complex
entity we have a receivership function
when banks failed taking the banks over
to make sure insured depositors
are protected we have an insurance
function we charge banks assessments
with charges and premiums for their
deposit insurance and we assess we just
those on the basis of risk
and so now we are reviewing our
assessments uh based on the experiences
and things that we've learned
as a result of this crisis to perhaps
readjust
some of the elements of those premiums
and then obviously we have a supervisory
function too we're the primary
supervisor federal supervisor for about
5000 state chartered banks so all three
put together
it keeps us busy and like mary we've
been very engaged on financial
regulatory reform on the hill too and
that's
taken a lot of time but it's time well
spent and i think we're very close i
think bipartisan
reform is within our grasp and uh and
we'll work with the treasury in the sec
and all the others
to try to get get to the finish line on
that do you think women
bring something specific to a role you
know when when people ask
me to speak at women and money um events
i sometimes say look thank you but that
sounds like marketing to me that you
know we all want to
invest and save wisely for the long term
men and women the same
but then again women and men are
different in in their approach to things
uh what kind of different value added do
you think women bring to the table
anybody i am if i could answer that in
the context of developing countries
perhaps this is fresh on my mind because
i was a
participant participated in a wonderful
program recently called vital voices
which recognizes women throughout the
globe who have taken heroic
steps to to help other women and the
woman i gave the award to had launched a
microfinance program in pakistan
and the overwhelming majority of the
small business entrepreneurs who were
borrowing money from her in these very
small increments
were women and she talked about the
incredible multiplier effect
in lending to women in these developing
countries has because not only does it
start businesses
and provide economic output but the
money tends to stay in the family and is
applied for children's education health
care whatever
and sorry guys but it's not so much when
the when the loans are made to the men
and the women are better credit risks
too they'll do a better job of repaying
their lives
so i think uh i think uh in in that
context in particular i think
uh women's attitudes is money uh towards
money uh
to uh produce value to support families
uh to provide that that social
uh benefit to their entrepreneurship i
think is
is really proving itself out in
developing countries so that a a little
more conservative view as far as saving
and investing from women
is is keeping it in the family yes
christina
so i'm not sure that there's you know in
in the economic policy making realm that
there's that much of a difference i
think
mainly it just doubles the talent pool
right if you can
um make sure that you have you know all
of the talent that's out there
represented in the policy
process i think it's just very helpful
go ahead elizabeth did you want to say
that i was going to say i i'm with
christine on this and yet
i think sometimes there are different
perspectives that
that women bring to the table you know i
think about it i think about a
conference
that i went to it's been several years
ago but you'll understand the connection
and now that was on financial innovation
and all of the conversation about
innovation was exclusively
about mortgage-backed securities
asset-backed securities right
derivatives derivatives squared and
cubed all these really cool things
and it was only the two women in the
room
uh who wanted to talk about what
financial innovation has meant
at the household level at the family
level where innovation has meant
things like liars loans and and
you know credit cards that nobody can
understand and and and
new forms of uh of
of tricks and traps and you know other
things that i've written a lot about but
but the point is it was it was as if
indeed this point was made rather
directly by one of the men running the
conference
no no there's only one view of what
constitutes
innovation there's only one perspective
that we want to bring to this and this
is a kind of
macro moving big money all at once
and the notion that what happens at the
family level
uh both as a driver of the economics and
in the fallout from some of the things
that were happening
was just not on the table now you know
can a man see that certainly there are
people who do there are people who care
about this but
as a group um it seems to me that women
are more
more willing to raise those issues that
makes sense because you're coming to the
table with a different
a different set of tools being you know
the head of a family
so you're you're thinking perhaps a
little differently
i guess i would add that i think that
diversity of experience whether it's
diversity of experience because of your
gender or your socioeconomic class
or any other reason is what's really
important here and that
we get better decisions secretary
geithner cited the
statistic about boards with women tend
to perform better
i think when you get that diversity of
views and that willingness to challenge
the status quo that you often get from
people who are new to an area whether
it's women whether it's
other other groups that's a really good
result at the end of the day and so
i think it does double our our work pool
which is a terrific thing but i think it
also gives us
just some different perspectives that
ultimately will lead to better decisions
and you've all had various roles on your
climb
to to this position right now have you
faced
barriers as a result of being a woman
along the way
what kind of tough situations did you
face do you think because you were in a
boys club
oh what kind have you not faced
you know i i mean besides
being the only woman at how many
different conferences i mean the good
news is there's never a line in the
ladies room
uh but unless unless sometimes the the
ladies room is in the basement like
new york exactly right been there at
those meetings
but i think when i was very young
and started teaching in a field like
this
there were people who not only thought
but who were actually willing to say
um you in effect must not know what
you're talking about
because you're young and female and uh
so how did you react to that you know
it's
funny i i actually remember um a student
who was older than i was uh and who had
made a lot more money
than i was ever going to make in my life
and who had come back to school
and i was just a baby teacher and i was
teaching commercial transactions class
you know boy that's
that's the serious stuff and you put
business deals together and here's how
you finance them and here's how it works
and as i would teach this goes a huge
class and as i would teach this class
i can still remember where i sat i could
pick the seat in the room if we went in
there
third one over second row and he would
say
yeah well i would teach he's like oh
and you know as i would keep teaching
and um
so this went on for a couple of weeks
and i just thought i'll ignore this come
on
i'm bigger than this i can i can manage
this until the day came
that a group of students came to see me
and i won't give you the full version of
the story but it ended with
professor warren this shouldn't be
happening give us the word we'll stop it
and i thought
so this really does disrupt the entire
the entire dynamic of this class of a
160 165 people
and so the next class
we had socratic dialogue
and really examined how much he knew
about finance and it turned out i really
know more than he did
and everyone in the room kind of calmed
down but but i think the truth is i
think we ignore this unpleasant truth
sometimes what's required is that you
just have to lean back and sock somebody
on the back
um get going sorry but
it is part of and then everyone can
relax and say oh everybody here knows
what they're talking about good luck
come on christy come on give us your
stories
it's been there i i have been there i
think in many ways i mean again
economics is something that is opening
up and i think it's really just a
triumph that
you know now when we look at the job
market of new phds coming out very often
the very top
few candidates are women so i think it
is a
a world that is changing i think in
macroeconomics which is my field it's
actually
still very male dominated and i have
exactly the same
experience of the only woman in the room
or one of two and it is it is somewhat
isolating i think
you know the other place where i feel
it's a disadvantage is not
so much in the you know the the obvious
professional
at the conference you're presenting
people listen to you but it's much more
the casual the forming co-author
relationships those kind of things where
somehow
it there is still a barrier and i think
it is something that is
is hard to get over i think the other
thing that i have definitely noticed
uh in the white house and elsewhere is
just difference in how
people communicate right i've never had
to interrupt people before in my life
right this is sort of
the just simply the the
aggressiveness or the taking turns
you've got to push your way in there
you just sometimes you got to just speak
up even when there isn't a gap in the
conversation
isn't it interesting that um and i
thought this this stat was really
interesting that 60 percent of the
higher degrees today
are going to women around the world even
in iran where they're covered up you
know you've got
60 percent of women getting the higher
degrees in law school and business
school and med school
and yet we get
all the way there after all of that
training we get the job
and we make 20 less than your male
counterpart
why is that you think i think texan
will take a lot of time i was
just um remind you that the first time i
stood up to give a speech as the
chairman of the commodity futures
trading commission number of years ago
talk about a male dominated industry i
mean the derivatives trading and
commodities trading was surely that way
and standing up there giving my maiden
speech and searching the audience for
just
one or two women i could focus on when i
was talking thinking there would be
empathy sheila was there
thank heavens thinking there would be
some empathy um
for the position i was in but i do think
um
it gives you a certain resilience and a
certain toughness when you have to go
through those very isolating
experiences um in in in the field that's
particularly male dominated
i think on the on the compensation
issues i think it will take time i mean
clearly most
most law school graduates now are women
i'm sure that's increasingly true in
other
finance related fields and at some point
there
the balance will tip and women will be
in a position
um to be paid equally um with men why it
hasn't happened yet as
is a bit of a mystery to me and then
really an unfortunate circumstance
is it still because we leave to go have
babies and then have to come back and
start at square one i mean no seriously
that was that was the reason that
everyone
you know gave over the years that women
leave the workforce
have babies and then come back and have
to start at a lower level or a lower pay
scale
would you say that's the reason or is it
something else from now on i think when
i'm interviewing ceos i'm going to ask
them
so if you were hiring a man or a woman
and the same uh
resume would you pay the woman less just
put some embarrassment out there
i think you know i think there's a
tendency uh with some
uh not with all uh with some to to value
us less whether it's our opinion whether
it's our work product
i think there is that kind of a still
perception there and so i think
you just recognize that as a fact of
life and and you have to work harder and
excel at your job
to make people recognize you and make
people realize the value of your work
because your work is valuable
i do think there's some yeah i think the
the the uh the motherhood thing can can
weigh against us i think
the perception that there's a guy at
home that's going to be making this much
if not more money you don't need it as
well i think that
that is probably still there too though
those are those are not legal anymore to
consider those but they're probably
with some uh not with all with some
probably still there
but i do think the employer is looking
at you saying look you've got a husband
they're making a lot of money too
or they're making you're fine right yeah
somebody else will take care of you
right exactly so but i will say uh i
think
being a woman has a lot of advantages
too i will say that and i think
yes it is i think uh you know it's it's
it's always depending on who you deal
with
uh but i know early in my career uh i
received a lot of mentoring from
senator bob dole who i work for and i
think particularly that world war ii
generation
of fathers who who had daughters and
were uh in family situations where it
was not exp
you know accepted for women to go out
and work i think there was a special
recognition by a lot of them
uh to support and mentor young
professional women and i know i
benefited from that and probably got
some extra attention i wouldn't have
gotten
uh if i had not been a woman so i think
you know with anything
you are who you are and with some people
help some people hurt but i think the
most important thing is to just
do your job and do it well and
ultimately you'll succeed that's that's
great advice we want to get to all the
questions from the audience as well as
we've got a lot of questions coming on
uh people who have tweeted it's that
yeah if they tweeted um on twitter and
i'm just kidding and on email as well
but but let me let me get your
state of the states before we go into
that christina if you had to
talk to college students or mbas right
now coming out of school
what what would you uh advise them where
are the jobs i mean this is a tough
economy we all know that
so what would be your best advice for
people today
well i think you know as secretary
geithner mentioned i think we are
on the road to recovery and i think that
is uh
a lot better than where we were a year
ago which was
certainly a very frightening time you
know so i think what is true is the
economy is growing again it's still
going to be a very tough job market for
quite a while i think that is the sad
reality and i think
you know i'll put in a plug i think we
need to be doing as much as possible
to try to to make the unemployment rate
come down much more quickly than it
than it is and is likely to so i think
that's uh important
for young people today i think it's
probably what sheila just said i think
perseverance
is going to be important i think being
flexible is going to be unbelievably
important in a in a tight job market the
ability to get the ideal job in the
ideal place is probably going to be much
harder so you're going to have to
to just say let me make the most of
of where i am now so so on a practical
level if i'm coming out of school
what does that mean in other words where
are the jobs so i think you know what
is still true education and health care
are the fields that have grown through
this whole recession and we certainly
anticipate them
continuing to grow i think in
a lot of the professional
services industries that's going to
continue to grow
you know i'm hopeful that manufacturing
will come back and i think there's going
to be
you know roles there for both managers
for the people coming out of college but
also for
workers looking for a a well-paying job
even with just a high school education
so i think
those are all reasonable reasonable
prospects any other thoughts on people
watching right now wanting to get ahead
in their job or
coming out of school one thing i would
add is that obviously getting the job is
critical
getting a job in something you love to
do is really
be the right answer for sort of
long-term economic success and
success and long-term happiness and so i
understand there are
some limited opportunities right now for
young people coming out of college and
graduate school
but if you can focus on what really
gives you
a sense of excitement that desire to
wake up every morning and rush into work
that's really the right way to go yeah
you know i i also would point out
it's a good time to think about getting
more education i got to put in a plug
for my business
uh but but it is it's a good time to go
back when
when there aren't lots of good jobs out
there then go get some extra training go
get a master's degree and something else
go get an undergraduate
degree go get an aaa if you don't have
one but now is a good time to
to to build your credentials to expand
what it is that you can do
the second thing i'd say is you can also
look at this
really lousy job market in a different
way and that is no one holds it against
you if you don't get the kind of
standard job
next in line for you it feels like oh
yeah wow it was really terrible job
market
which means you can be a lot more
creative about the
sorts of things that you can take on
go work for somebody interesting and
maybe it doesn't look like a great job
on paper first time out but if you're
working with somebody interesting
interesting things happen and you'll
have other opportunities that will open
up once your foot's in the door
so i think this is really an opportunity
to say you know
maybe i had this grand plan for how i do
this for five years and then this for
ten more and then i'd be on this path
that i could see in advance
let me tell you the most successful
people i know
the path doesn't look anything like they
thought it was going to look back when
they started it everyone has reshifted
and redone
and replayed recognize that right up
front
and just work out your own two-year plan
just say two years and at the end of two
years
what would i know that i didn't know now
where where would be a job that could
make me a kind of more
interesting more thoughtful person than
i was
because you know the truth is christina
there are areas that that are in need of
of
new help and and mary you have to love
what you do and that's the only way
you're going to work really hard at
right and then maybe get a little luck
and and elizabeth everything's changing
uh so you need new skill sets and you
may need new training
any thoughts on that sheila well we're
hiring
we've grown from five thousand we're
highly counter cyclical
so yes fdic.gov if you are interested in
bulking up too right
i think that's right you need to be
flexible now and uh for those who've
been in the workforce so maybe having uh
some problems in the current job
environment i think going back and
getting education is absolutely the
right move
we will get through this i think
washington is very focused the
administration certainly is very focused
on unemployment that is that is i agree
with christina the central issue right
now
and so we will get through this and i
think uh doing something that you love
and or that will lead to something that
she will love i think is uh is a wise
goal
but for now you probably do need to be
flexible just i think we're only half
just in
public service is really it is a
wonderful opportunity and it's so
enriching
and rewarding that people should really
consider it even if you thought i'll
never go be
a government bureaucrat there's a lot to
commend it
do you consider yourself a government
bureaucrat nope not a bank
all right here's a question from jack
ackerman from richard stockton college
of new jersey
what is the best path you feel a fresh
college graduate should take in this
economy private sector or public
yes yes
whatever looks like the right job i just
think i i don't think they divide in
that way
i should put my resume in both places
and see what kind of opportunities open
up
um because there's good stuff in both
places and frankly they're really
boring things to do in both places so so
it really it really doesn't
you don't want to distinguish how about
this one here this is from megan carr
richard stockton college of new jersey
how has the role of women in any type of
job changed
since you started participating in the
jobs market
has the role of women changed well i
think there absolutely are more
opportunities
there's more work to be done but i think
we are taken more seriously we are given
more opportunities for advancement
we do have a seat at the table and more
of the key meetings
and we still have to you know to fight
to to get into the
the key decision making but there are a
lot more opportunities it has changed
and i think that's going to continue i
really do
agree with that anybody else nothing
else has changed
what are some of the positive effects
women bring to the financial sector we
probably we probably touched on that but
um as far as as far as the financial
sector in general
do you still find that you are one of
the few
in a sea of suits or mostly male male
dominated
in in all of your roles
right yeah i mean it is changing i mean
i think
you know i'll actually say one of the
nice things about the white house is i
actually have
more women around me than i had in my
academic life and so it has you know
at some level it's just natural
interaction but there is i think
a special bond and i and i definitely
have the sense of
each of us looking out for the other a
certain amount and i think that is
really fantastic is that by design did
you did you set up lots of women around
you as well as
as well as men or did you set that up i
mean i mean certainly when i hired i was
trying to look for the
best people in many cases the best
people were women i think
you know i think i give the president
and the people organizing the white
house a lot of credit that they were as
i mentioned earlier
looking broadly for talent and and
founded in some unusual places and it's
just a
fabulous environment this next question
is more about the state of states and
and really
where where are we um and it also brings
women into it this is from
uh jacinta duttenhofer richard stockton
college of new jersey
what are some specific ways you believe
pending changes to financial and banking
regulations
will help the american people and help
the financial system on sound
footing so putting being a woman aside
for a moment what's most important in
terms of financial
reform wow well there's a lot that's
important about it and it's an
opportunity
for us to do a lot of things better i
think going forward
i think the focus on on consumer banking
and elizabeth can speak
to that with tremendous knowledge is
going to be very important for women for
households for for americans going
forward
i think getting the largely unregulated
over-the-counter derivatives under the
regulatory umbrella is an
absolutely critical step for us to take
the focus on systemic risk regulation
resolution of financial institutions
all of those things are really very
important and and closing some of the
gaps that have been created over the
years
that really allowed our economy to end
up in really the dire circumstances we
have found ourselves in over the last
couple of years how will derivatives uh
transparency
impact the average guy or gal out there
well i mean if we need look only around
at the carnage on the street
largely as a result in some cases of
over-the-counter derivatives but
the extensive uh relationships between
financial institutions largely through
the counterparty risk that they created
in these over-the-counter derivatives
brought a lot of institutions
right to the brink and impacted the
availability of credit
um the soundness and trustworthiness of
financial institutions broadly but it's
important to remember
that i couldn't leave this without
putting in the plug
that this crisis started one lousy
mortgage at a time
the raw material that got fed into the
system were these
really terrible mortgages uh for which
there were some people who walked into
the eyes wide open and said you know i'm
gonna
roll the dice here and a system that
permitted that and on the other side
people who walked into these things
and had not a clue what was happening to
them always important to remember about
the subprime mortgage crisis
the first wave of selling subprime
mortgages was to people who already
owned
their own homes uh and uh managed to get
themselves refinanced right out of them
so the the consequences
of the the kind of of consumer credit
market that has evolved over the last 30
years
uh the notion of making profits over
fooling people
over tricking people has led not
only to the destabilization of american
families it's led to the destabilization
of the american economy
we dial that back with a consumer
financial protection agency with two
page credit card agreements and
mortgages that people can understand and
compare
we make a huge difference at the family
level
and at the at the economy level so that
consumer protection agency will be able
to
oversee and ensure that those bad
mortgages those mortgages on on
properties
that aren't worth what they said they
were worth will ensure that that doesn't
happen again i think the key way to say
it
is it actually repairs a broken market
the design is not to say thou shalt not
the design is really to say
both parties to a transaction the lender
and the borrower ought to be able to
understand the terms and the borrower
should be able to tell what the costs
are and the risks are up front
and should be able to compare say four
credit card agreements or four mortgage
agreements
and which one's cheaper and which one
carries more risk
if we can get that basic part of the
transaction back in place
i think we count on american families to
make pretty smart decisions
in general and we don't need a heavy
hand of regulation we just need enough
support to get this market working in
the right direction
i just wanted to follow up on something
that that mary said because i think we
can all see how important a consumer
financial protection agency is
but i also think just coming to what
sounds like a you know
big amorphous resolution authority or
making sure that someone is
you know regulating the big systemically
important uh
financial institutions those are
basically
family and jobs issues right so what we
are living through
is as mary said the carnage of this
system breaking down and i think the
reason
we are also committed to moving
financial regulatory reform
forward is precisely to make sure we are
never in this position again or
or just as you know our our grandparents
i guess in the great depression gave us
80 years of a system that
uh was stable we need to put in place a
regulatory structure that'll give us
another 80 years
um but we will right we'll see it more
bubbles we'll fall in love with
something again
and it will create euphoria and
over do you know it will be overdone
again i mean don't don't you think
yeah there are there are always cycles
though i think the the bill uh
that's moving through has passed the
house that's moving through the senate
will give us better tools so to tamp
down on those before they occur and then
when there are failures better tools to
deal with them and avoid these these
terrible bailouts that have created so
much
political controversy and undermining of
a public confidence in both the
financial institutions as well
as the government uh so i think it is
it's just common sense it's making loans
people
can afford to repay it's having some
transparency and basic policing of the
derivatives markets which magnified the
losses once the loans started
going bad you know i hope though that
we've also had a bit of a paradigm shift
in terms of how the country views
regulation
we went through so many years where
regulation was viewed as a way to stymie
innovation or creative competitive
disparities i mean how many times did we
have this arguments and
regulators are you know it's good to
pass new laws and come up with better
structures and better
regulatory tools but unless there's
political support for regulators to use
those tools
it just won't work and the reality is
that there were regulators
in the as this this thing kept getting
out of hand trying to curb it back and
got
no political support and a lot of
political opposition and even now as
we're coming out of the crisis
there is still a pressure not to
regulate and uh so i don't
believe in prescriptive regulation i
believe in free markets the difference
between free markets and free for all
markets you need some basic common sense
regulation and some rules and have the
rules enforced
i think it's very important for the
public generally to understand that and
help provide political support for that
very basic function
also a big change was 30 years ago when
you lent somebody money you lent
somebody
money and then they paid it back with
interest and that was it but today
you lend somebody and then they pass the
loan on to somebody else and and sort of
spreads the risk which is a
really important and interestingly
everyone thought we were really
spreading the risk of the securitization
of mortgages and other
receivables and and therefore we no
longer needed to worry about risk we no
longer needed to worry that the
underwriting standards had deteriorated
because i the bank wasn't going to be
responsible
all of you investors were going to buy
these asset-backed securities and share
the risk and of course
that's not really how it turned out we
weren't really dispersing risk through
the system
in some ways we were concentrating it
really interesting
let me ask you a question how do you
think things have changed already
sheila you just made an interesting
point you said we're going to see
um you know more changes and we've
already seen
a different perception uh as it relates
to the industry and
and certainly a different perception on
the part of regulators so
i i thought in my head and we've already
seen a change in terms of the perception
of wall street
so up until now even before we've got
the reform
and and we know that that's coming down
the pike what would you say
has already changed on wall street
well i'll just jump in i think much less
on wall street but we certainly see a
change in
how families are behaving so we
certainly see uh
we see savings rates are higher than
they had been
certainly in the mid 2000s when they
were down very very low so we do see i
think a new
caution on the part of households uh
wanting to you know sort of get their
financial lives in order and i think
that's going to be something i think
that's a positive development it is
something we're going to have to be
navigating we can't count on consumers
being the engine pulling us forward in
terms of a recovery and
and fast growth we have to be thinking
about well are other things taking the
place
like business investment or our net
exports that's going to be important but
it is a change in behavior
i hope this isn't just wishful thinking
on my part but i believe we're beginning
to see a change
in how corporations and their boards um
govern their activities and that they're
more focused on risk management they're
more focused on issues like
excessive executive compensation and how
that might be driving risk-taking and
and certainly we're seeing more activism
by institutional shareholders
to push boards in that direction and i
think that will overall be a very good
development
um for our economy but again i hope it's
not just wishful thinking i hope we're
actually seeing motion in that direction
that's an important point because that
really would be a critical uh sort of
cog in the wheel wouldn't it yeah
absolutely i i must say i i paused
because i i was
trying to say whether i should be honest
or not so i will be honest i i really
don't see it
i haven't seen anything change uh and i
know that's the provocative statement
and i hope mary's right but i'm not sure
i really have seen anything meaningfully
changed yet and i'm very concerned
that the uh the culture uh that led to
this crisis is still there
uh this kind of divorcement of views in
terms of what you're paid and what kind
of value you produce i i think
i regret to say that a lot of these
institutions i think that's still there
i don't see a lot of support or
prioritization of extending credit
to support the real economy i i just
will have to say that so
i do think uh further engagement you
can't categorize all large institutions
uh
in the same bucket and some clearly are
much better than others
in terms of the efforts they're making
now to support the economy
but i i don't can't say that i've really
seen a city have been culture shift and
i regret that because i think
you know if the extent is not done uh
through market mechanisms it will have
to be done with more prescriptive
regulation i don't think that's helpful
i did there are there are signs where
some investors have become more active
shareholders have become more active
and i think that's helpful uh but even
with some of the shareholders you've got
to distinguish sometimes from the
short-term and the long-term
shareholders and what their incentives
might be
so i hope i hope there is some
improvement but i'm not sure i see
conclusive evidence of it yet it's
really interesting i wonder if you think
college and mba and well higher
education
in general professors should be involved
in this um because
you know what's the success when you're
in school the success is getting a
recruiter to come to your college or
your
business school and say we're going to
offer you a lot of money to come the
allure is still compensation
so do we need this to be sort of put on
its head to
try and get those people to instead of
going
uh to pursue money to pursue their dream
like you said mary at the start of this
that you really have to love
what you do so should colleges and and
higher education
leaders be involved in this in terms
because we all know that you know over
the years financial services had become
so big
um and all of the talented people or a
lot of talented people coming out of
schools were going there for the lure of
compensation as opposed to
doing some of the underpinnings that
perhaps the economy needed like in
biotech or healthcare or manufacturing
or whatever
so should we be appealing to some i
think so yeah i think
financial services got too big it just
got too big it is
it keeps consuming a disproportionately
a large share of our our resources our
talent
and i absolutely think uh it needs to
downsize that as happening to some
extent and and that talent needs to be
drawn back into uh
efforts that more directly support the
real economy so i think that it's
absolutely a trend that we need to see
and are starting to see
here's a question from gia huang in yale
graduated in 2011 in the not so distant
past men completely dominated all
aspects of corporate and governmental
leadership
so it's inspiring to see that today
increasingly more women are rising to
the top
what do you think are the primary
drivers of this and what are the
obstacles to this positive trend
one of the drivers is it had to happen
at some point
good grief uh the numbers
are just there i i i think every time we
talk about this
i'm reminded of the fact that 30 years
ago i looked around my law school
graduating class and we were
women were nearly half and i thought
yeah we
okay we got real problems right now
about getting hired in the big firms and
whether or not we're going to move
forward but time will solve this problem
if we are graduating in big numbers if
we have those strong educations where
half the talent pool
will be there and now we celebrate the
fact that hey we made it to two percent
30 years later in terms of the you know
the big companies this is
nuts so my view is
about this that yeah i celebrate i'm
glad that that's the case
but time alone is not going to solve
this problem
we have to be affirmatively thoughtful
about how it is that women and other
groups
that are underrepresented on wall street
we talked today here about women but
let's face it we are not the only group
that is underrepresented on wall street
how it is that those people will be
brought in
how all of us will be brought in to the
to the entire
sector and i think part of the answer
there
is sometimes you just have to be much
more conscious
about about what it is
that that that breeds success it's not
enough to have a good education
we've proven that we tried it but it's
all the other things how often do women
get a chance to talk how often do they
get invited to speak how
often do you say i'm going to bring
three more women in with me how often
when a woman speaks do you say
afterwards that was a good point
the the studies are starting to come out
now those
take a look at the serious sociology and
psych studies on this
about how perpetually we expect to hear
men's voices
we listen to men's voices we think men's
voices carry more authority than women's
voices
if we don't retrain ourselves as a
people
both men and women then what we'll be
doing is we'll have another one of these
events 30 years from now
and women leaders in finance will still
fit on a very small stage
what do you do when you have worked on a
report or worked on a project and you
and your heart of hearts know that this
is the right way to go
and you present it to your bosses who
may be
male i mean christina you walk into the
president's office and
and you say this is where i think we
should go president obama and he says no
no no that's not where we're going to go
what how do you push back
can you push back absolutely i mean this
year
sure you have done so um so no i mean
you mean yes you have to
you know i think the the key thing is to
do the best
work that you can and to have a very
strong point of view you
make that case and sometimes you make it
many times and sometimes you can make
yourself kind of annoying and then
you know at some point either you you
know
everybody agrees or you lose and and you
go on but i think
the important thing have you tried right
have you given it the best chance
possible
have you done your homework in terms of
seeing if you can get allies right so
often you know not just to be the lone
voice but to learn to work cooperatively
it takes courage
it does but you don't want to work for
somebody who doesn't want you to push
back
because at the end of the day what's the
value of being surrounded by people who
tell you
what you already think you haven't
advanced the ball you haven't really
engaged the discussion
at all that way you want to work for
someone who will let you say
exactly what you think and have the
debate and and the discussion with you
at the end of the day everybody needs to
to march in the same direction and
that's why you're on the team by the way
because
exactly but you brought people who will
give you the opposing view or you're
you're not going to make good decisions
i think that's right i mean
we get to be the boss we have male and
female staffers presenting ideas to us
but i think that's right uh someone who
will come in and advocate uh will will
be prepared to respond to questions
who's really thought through the
proposal
uh you know i really respect that i
think employees do that are more
valuable than than anyone
so people become well prepared and will
will stick up for their position i think
that's that's something i you know i
want to hear
questions from the audience
initiatives that you have you laid out
the three different initiatives that you
have commissioner
and one of them was in investor
confidence and and really bringing them
back into the fold
i'm on the board of several boards but
travelers insurance
and we deal with risk management all the
time we look at this
and i often joke that we need a license
to drive a car but we don't need a
license
to buy some of these innovative products
can you talk a little bit about what the
sec can do to really
help investors women understand
about money but how they can understand
about risk and if there's something we
can do in the private sector to partner
with you well i think there's a lot the
private sector can and should be doing
and if you look at different financial
institutions websites some do a pretty
good job actually
trying to impart basic investor
education information i think that's
really critical
you know i have a very much a personal
view not an sec view that we ought to
have
a minimum requirement for graduation
from high school
of uh economic and investor knowledge in
order to
you know when i went to high school you
had to get home economics
credit we would have been a lot better
off getting an investor education credit
and i really think that that's something
that
that as a country we ought to be
supporting very broadly the sec
has just actually reinvigorated um with
some terrific new talent our office of
investor education and advocacy and
we're partnering with the rest of the
federal government but also
everywhere we can with advocacy groups
to really help people
understand the basics of investing
reaching out in the schools
working with different foundations and
i think it's really important but i also
think it's important for us
it's great to teach people and to teach
them as young as we can and all through
their lives about
investing but we as an agency also need
to make sure that we've given them the
tools
to understand the financial products
that's that are being presented to them
so
great disclosure at the point of sale
about mutual fund fees and expenses and
risks for example
or better information about how to vote
their proxy once they are an investor
and they own shares
how do you vote the proxy what does it
mean to vote a proxy it's really
important
that people do those things so we're
trying through our rule making
in addition to our educational and
advocacy efforts to really
give investors the tools they need um
to understand the products that are
being presented to them
that's a great point the problem is
nobody ever teaches you this stuff and
then you become an adult and you're
you still don't know you're embarrassed
and then you're embarrassed or you
learned in school because you joined the
investment club but it's not part of the
curriculum and
that's not a that's not a way to get an
educated nation of investors
absolutely yes i remember meeting um
division of finance alan beller at the
time and suggesting doing a town hall
and getting out to different groups back
in september too he now serves on our
board of travelers
but i i think if there's some
constructive way that we could do a
partnership i'd be interested in
learning a little bit more
great yeah we'll we'll uh continue
talking about that if you want after
in terms of partnerships we want to get
as many questions as possible yes
hello kathleen connell um berkeley i
would like to
really focus on retirement at a point
where
many of our 401ks have been depleted and
when you look at women in particular
they're spending an average of less than
uh 12 years less than the in the
workforce than men
they have 78 cents on the dollar to the
men that they're working with
uh they're much more likely at age 65 to
be single
or widowed or divorced how do we begin
to get women to be
money smart as it as it affects their
retirement
and what can all of you and your various
agencies and physicians do to advance
this issue
of women's security and retirement
because women are very much on their own
as they as they approach that much more
important issue of
security well let me take a very narrow
slice of that because i think the
educational efforts are critically
important
but we also have to do something to
ensure that a lot of the products that
are now being
innovated for the retirement market are
in fact
products that are designed to serve the
interest of the retiree or the
soon-to-be retiree
not designed for the purpose of
generating new fees and revenues for the
financial institutions that created them
so
from my perspective one of the critical
things for the sec to do is to really
understand these products
warn investors about those that that
should they should be warned about bring
enforcement cases
aggressively and quickly when the trust
and confidence of of people investing in
these retirement products
has been violated christina how did you
learn about money i mean you all
are all so successful and we're trying
to figure out
how it is that others can become
so successful but did you learn it
at home when you were young did you
learn it in school
i think it is you know i think you know
getting into economics i actually often
tell the story i was all set to be a
lawyer
and i was going to major in political
science and when i went to
college in political science they made
us take a year of economics and it was
just like
you know a light went off i i loved it
and
you know so i've ended up learning about
money sort of
by the back door right so you learn the
theory of you know various things in
finance
and then you bring that into your into
your everyday life so
in school and you just took to it and
just took to it
elizabeth you know i i was going to say
on the point about
women that you talk about that really
interests me this question about
retirement
is that i support everything mary's
talking about about the importance of
the retirement
accounts and kind of the products that
are available but i think that when we
talk about
financial education we're starting one
level too high
when we talk about things like how
people should learn
proxy statements and how stock works and
so on because
as dull as it sounds i think it starts
with basic budgeting
and that there's no one on the side of
teaching consumers about
must-have expenses about flexible
spending and about savings
that that we are perpetually bombarded
about spend spend spend spend spend and
to the extent there's anything on
retirement
a lot of it is fee driven let's let's
face it that's what's going on
and so i think the the whole notion
about how we
think about the education of around
money is that we really haven't
established
core principles and you know if you're
if you're well off
thinking about how to invest your money
that you know you should be setting
aside for your 401k or whatever
good those are good decisions to make
but for a lot of people it's never even
getting to that point and many of the
women you were talking about
you know i'd add just one more if i can
when we talk about retirement
the number one retirement plan in
america is not a 401k or savings account
it's pay off your house
and live on your social security the
devastation
that has been wrought over the past
decade
by the depletion of equity in homes
that this entire housing bubble was
actually accompanied by
a decrease in the amount of equity that
people own
and a reduction in the number of people
as they hit their 55
60 65 who had their homes paid off and
could live in those homes
tab for the remainder of their lives and
and live on their social security that
has been wiped out
for literally millions of families and
we're going to pay the price for that
for another generation so so i just want
to suggest
we have a lot broader thinking to do in
this area
yep it's worth just examining how you
get smart about money i mean i learned
it at home you know
basic things don't spend what you don't
have and that
stayed with me forever but you have to
start at home and then in school
we all benefited probably i think most
of us from having parents who were the
product of the depression
right and so at home we did learn
exactly those kinds of lessons but this
next generation
has grown up under very different
circumstances and some are products of
the dot-com boom
right we also lived in houses in homes
that
that our parents weren't financed on
credit that's right my parents didn't
have a credit card not because they were
somehow
morally superior to everyone else or had
more money
they just weren't around so their
parents lived on
campus they wouldn't take think of
taking on such high
debts they took on were medical debts to
keep us healthy um
their home mortgage and that was it not
to flip a house
that's right i don't think my parents
would have understood that
yes hi we've established that uh women
earn less than men
on average um but we also know anybody
who here who has a household that women
tend to run the household budget
often and as personal finance
journalists i go around the country
and i meet many unsophisticated people
who don't have much money have no idea
how their mortgage works
and i meet a lot of very sophisticated
very smart phd
mbas who also have no idea how their
mortgage works
um and i wanted to ask you know
obviously elizabeth warren
and senator geithner have been very
vocal about their support for the
consumer financial protection agency
and i wanted to get a sense from you all
how likely will it be to achieve that
basic goal
of just understandable language plain
vanilla mortgages
credit cards even payday loans and what
to understand about them
and what is the obstacle and how can we
either women or people in general
should work to get this in there will it
be part of the consumer protection
agency this education financial literacy
is that
where where does this piece go i believe
the house and senate bills both have a
significant financial education
component
in the consumer agency because the
agency is built on that principle
it is not built on the nanny principle
of you can't do this and you shouldn't
do that you're not allowed to do this
it's built on the principle of people
being able to read
and understand their credit agreements
and the fundamentals for that are
consumer education
it doesn't do any good to be able to to
read them
if you can't then integrate them into
your own lives
every day so so i think it's a i think
it's an integral part of what this
agency is about
is to give a home to consumer education
and frankly right in the place it
belongs where people are trying to deal
with
with credit instruments but i think you
bring up an issue which is
you know this is something if you survey
the population
wildly enthusiastic right we want to be
have forms that we can understand we
want an agency that's only job is to
look out for consumers
and yet it seems to be one of the most
controversial pieces of
a very complex bill and it it is frankly
surprising i think we are going to have
to
work very hard to make sure that that
stays strong and and central
all right i would say too though i think
there's a market a strong market
argument for consumer protection that
perhaps doesn't get as much attention as
it should
because if consumers can't understand
what they're buying they can't
understand the price they can't
understand the features they can't make
economically rational decisions if they
don't know which credit card is the most
expensive because the disclosures are so
opaque
or the thing is just so complex nobody
can understand it they will not make an
economically
rational decision and that that
undermines the market so i think there
definitely is a strong market efficiency
argument but that's this
not a term used in vogue anymore but i
think it does support
the market so more efficiently to have
meaningful consumer protection and
disclosure and understandable
products we want to keep this on time so
we'll wrap it up ladies thank you very
much professor warren
chairman romer chairman shapiro
chairman bear thank you everybody
thank you
thank you again